it's time for seen and unseen where we
reveal the stories behind the headlines
for that we turn to Fox News contributor
Raymond aroyo all right Raymond good to
see you tonight the biggest cultural
story of the week I think is how the
Democrats are they're trying to
reframe old
Joe yeah well you know it's sort of
fascinating to watch Lura you have an
81-year-old cognitively challenged
president and all across the media the
new argument is Donald Trump is the one
with cognitive problems pay no attention
to the mental acuity of those making the
argument well let me just say I'm not
going to spend too much time on Donald
Trump's uh cognitive disorders he tried
to say that Nikki Haley did not allow
the National Guard to come but it was
Nancy Pelosi it was NE nobody it was Joe
it was Donald Trump I think when you see
Donald Trump in the spotlight every day
doing things like confusing Nikki Haley
who he's running against with Nancy
Pelosi and uttering sort of nonsensical
sentences that don't make sense yes I
think that is going to raise concerns
for people you
might Laura this kind of commentary
takes real Stones I mean Pelosi still
think she's the speaker but look this is
Joe Biden today and yesterday I'm going
to let people decide for themselves here
he is speaking to his supporters and
protesters we'll teach Donald Trump an
valuable lesson don't mess with a women
America unless you want to get the
benefit any product that in fact
Congress any money that Congress gives
the president to spend to build a prod
whether it's an aircraft carrier an
automobile a tank or a staircase no
matter what that was it should be
[Applause]
built Because of You Toyota Volkswagen
Nissan Tulsa all gave their workers
double digit raises because of you
Tulsa that's a new car manufacturer La
at Tulsa look if Trump said this it
would be wall-to-wall coverage but with
Biden there's no coverage at all
apparently the UAW and its endorsement
of Biden today is just decided it wants
to get out of the automobile industry
altogether because there will be no
americanmade cars by the end of the uh
Biden Administration well Laura earlier
you mentioned the Network's curtailing
coverage of trump they just cut him off
with Biden they cut him off as well to
protect his blunders from being seen and
now whatever people want to say voters
are not blind I mean when you see these
two men side by side a simple question
emerges who would you rather represent
the United States of America at say a
confrontation with Putin or X that's the
question Americans have to figure up
that gate always gives it away Ray the
gate all right the amazing thing though
is is that along with the Democrats
Nikki Haley is now making an age an
issue as well using a Democrat talking
point I've long called for mental
competency tests for politicians over
the age of
75 most
Americans do not want a rematch between
Biden and
Trump the first party to retire its
80-year-old candidate is going to be the
party that wins this election
h i I think I figured it out Laura I
guess now it's okay for candidates to
talk about age unless you're Don Lemon
she says people you know politicians or
something are not in their Prime Nikki
Haley isn't in her prime sorry when a
woman is considered to being in her
prime in her 20s and 30s and maybe
40s remember that routine Nikki Haley
you know she blew her top over this and
look Don Lemon made a stupid comment
Nikki Haley's making a stupid comment
today a person person is in their Prime
when they realize their purpose no
matter their age it isn't it isn't
dictated by how many years you've racked
up you know Raymond I always say I like
to hang around with old people and the
young people it's the people in the
middle who are the problem that's I like
the old and young they're fine okay
finally there probably won't be a new
Barbie Academy Award play set Laura the
Barbie movie received eight Academy
Award nominations just Ken got a Best
Supporting Actor nod but Ryan Gosling
who played Ken says he's disappointed
that the director Greta Gerwig and
actress Margo Robbie were snubbed Oscar
winner whoopy Goldberg is having none of
it get everything that you want to get
they're not snubs and that's what I want
to sort of point out not everybody gets
surpris and it is subjective movies are
subjective the movies you love may not
be loved by the people who are
voting you know Laura I love when Elites
complain go talk to your people in the
industry who vote on the awards if
anybody was sned it was sound of Freedom
which was the number one independent
movie of the year and the top 10 top
earner they got no nominations at stop
complaining this is makes me want to
throw pink Ray isn't goling just trying
to Virtue signal that I'm for the I'm
for the gals you can't call them gals
I'm for the ladies I can't call I'm for
the women that that's what he's doing
right it's all kind of virt signaling
while he takes home his Golden Globes
and Oscars yeah I have not seen
and I don't feel like I'm neglecting
myed intellectual theatrical
understanding Raymond thank you all
right don't forget to set your DVR and
remember Jesse is next hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else